my beloved dune books what I wouldn't
give to live in the doom universe to
study the ways of AB in each ezrin to
know the taste of melange I'll just
ignore that cool hot oh well I guess it
is time goodbye for now dune universe
I'll be back
[Music]
hey guys it's been a couple of weeks
since my last student video so it's time
for me to do a roundup video on all the
news that has come out since first off
director denis villeneuve has come out
and said some pretty interesting things
about the upcoming film we've gotten
multiple images of characters from the
film but there is one character that
we've still all been kind of inkling to
see that we haven't gotten a single
glimpse of yet and that character is of
course Shai allude the great worm of the
desert in an interview with Empire
magazine Villeneuve gave details about
the design of the legendary worms of
Arrakis noting that they took a year to
design the look of it we talked about
every little detail that would make such
a beast possible from the texture of the
skin to the way the mouth opens to the
system to eat its food in the sand Vilno
said to Empire it was a year of work to
design and find the perfect shape that
looked prehistoric enough firstly
hearing that they took a year to design
the worm really makes me happy it really
shows that they care about what they are
doing enough to make sure that it's
right I love that they considered how
the creature would actually operate if
it were actually to exist and allow that
to inform the design of it Frank Herbert
does do some describing of the worms at
several times in the series and I'll
list a few of those examples this is one
from the first book then they saw it a
wide hole emerged from the sand sunlight
flashed from glistening white spokes
within it the holes diameter was at
least twice the length of the crawler
Paul estimated he watched as the machine
slid into that opening in a billow of
dust and sand the hole pulled back here
Frank Herbert describes an enormous
creature capable of swallowing an entire
spiced crawler hole he describes
countless glistening white teeth lining
the hole that is the creatures mouth
this next passage here is also from the
book dune
instead of frightening him the sensation
of time darkness forced a hyper
acceleration of his other senses he
found himself registering every
available aspect of the thing that
lifted from the sand there seeking him
its mouth was some 80 meters in diameter
crystal teeth with the curved shape of
Chris knives glinting around the rim the
bellows breath of cinnamon subtle
aldehydes acids small spoiler alert'
though it's been like 60 years since
dune came out the biological functions
of the worms are inextricably linked to
the substance known as the spice melange
that is why Paul can smell cinnamon
wafting off of the creature the books
also reference an internal furnace the
worm seemed to produce an immense amount
of heat as a byproduct of their
biological processes here's an awesome
quote from the book heretics of doon
which refers to the worms inner furnace
the tubular surface vents of the cannot
lay no more than 50 meters in front of
its gaping mouth she smelled the hot
cinnamon exaltations heard the deep
rumblings of shaytans interior furnace
so the worms of the desert are quite
monstrous and terrifying
not to mention huge side note this isn't
a lore video but since we were talking
about how terrifying the worms are I
thought I would take a bit of time to
consider Frank Herbert's sand worms
thematically when we were first
introduced to the sand worms they are
exalted God's to the Fremen
they called the worms shahe lewd which
meant something like old Father eternity
old man of the desert or grandfather of
the desert but I personally suspect that
the reason Frank Herbert named this
creature shahe lewd was because of what
he intended to do for books later
keep in mind Herbert spent six years
planning before he wrote a single word
of dune the series has to be considered
as a whole so as I said the worms are
considered the gods of the desert
initially but as thousands of years pass
and human society continues to evolve
the worms are eventually viewed quite
differently by the people of
desert by the book heretics of tune the
worms of the desert have gone from being
considered gods to being considered
Devils and the people of the desert call
him by the name Shaytan
now Shaytan unlike shahe lute is an
actual real word which literally means
Satan
this is absolutely intentional and
that's not all heretics have doin
greatly expands upon the themes
involving the worms of the desert with
quite the hellish reference I should say
check out this passage as it stopped
Oh trade became conscious of the deep
furnace rumbling of the worm she could
not tear her gaze away from the
reflection of lamb bein orange flames
within the creature it was a cave of
mysterious fire before I get to the real
point one cool thing about this
description is that it describes a
glowing furnace inside the worm we've
never really seen that in any adaptation
and I personally think that it is an
interesting aesthetic feature of the
worms I mean can you imagine how good
that would look in a scene that took
place at night it would be horrifying
but that's obviously not what's actually
important here
I believe that Frank Herbert describes
the creatures mouth as a cave of
mysterious fire because he is attempting
to evoke images of a hellish inferno the
image of a cave calls forth images from
the opening of Dante's Divine Comedy
where Dante stands before the entrance
to hell and written above the entrance
are the words abandon all hope all who
enter here if you don't know the Divine
Comedy which was completed by Dante in
1320 details a man's journey through
Hell where he eventually crawls up the
body of Satan in order to enter limbo
and finally ascends to heaven after
climbing up stone steps of the mountain
of purgatory and paradise he glimpses
God and has met with an understanding
and he cannot express and in that moment
he understands God and the divinity of
Christ and his soul is aligned with gods
in the scene in heretics of dune we're
owed raid sees shaytan's cave of
mysterious fire she too is beginning a
journey
and though she senses great danger she
like Dante is resigned to whatever fate
he will face she enters the cave of
mysterious fire climbs on the back of
Shaytan who leads her to a literal cave
where she then climbs up rock stairs
just as Dante climbed up the rock stairs
of the mountain of purgatory in the
purgatory Oh section of the Divine
Comedy and then she has a conversation
with God discovering a message left for
her by the God Emperor Leto the second
and ultimately she aligns with his
purpose Oh Drake lime passed the
questions reading them a second time as
she went noble purpose what a fragile
thing that always was and how easily
distorted but the power was there
immersed in constant peril it was all
spelled out on the walls and stairs of
that chamber terraza knew without having
it explained the tyrants meaning was
clear join me the soul of the Binney
jazz Rey is aligned with gods just as
Dante's soul is aligned with God's Frank
Herbert even goes so far as to use the
word soul specifically when referring to
the Benny J's right to you I give the
certainty that the body and soul of the
Benny Jesuit will meet the same fate as
all other bodies and all other souls
Frank Herbert is definitely referencing
the Divine Comedy here in my opinion and
the worm itself is both God and the
devil
not only has Frank Herbert created his
own version of the Divine Comedy he is
showing us how religions and beliefs and
myths evolved over thousands of years
the gods of the past are the devil's of
the future and this has been a
consistent fact throughout all of human
history during the rise of Christianity
countless pagan gods and symbols were
demonized and became associated with
malignancy and evil shahe lewd became
Shaytan God became the devil
all right kids that's enough class for
today back to business I'm excited to
see what Villeneuve's interpretation of
the Arrakis sandworm looks like
hopefully he can capture the grand
magnificence of the creature denis
villeneuve also compared Paul to Michael
Corleone from The Godfather when
speaking to Empire magazine Paul has
been raised in a very strict environment
with a lot of training because he is the
son of a Duke and one day he's training
to be the Duke Vilno tells Empire but as
much as he's been prepared and trained
for that role is it really what he
dreams to be that's the contradiction of
that character it's like Michael
Corleone from The Godfather
it's someone that has a very tragic fate
and he will become something that he was
not wishing to become come on guys this
dude gets it he understands what
jodorowsky did not get he understands
what David Lynch did not get Paul
Atreides is not the hero of the dune
saga which you've heard me say a
thousand times on this channel
definitely check out this video right
here of me explaining exactly why it is
the case that Paul is not the hero tune
if you don't know about that
like I said countless times I don't
think there's a better person for this
film than Villeneuve he understands
what's going on here next up here's a
bit of kind of shady business so several
days ago
Warner Media Group accidentally I guess
leaked a synopsis for the upcoming HBO
Mac show doomed The Sisterhood the page
has now been taken down but I do have a
screenshot of what the synopsis said an
adaptation of Brian Herbert and Kevin J
Anderson 's book based in the world
created by Frank Herbert's dune dune The
Sisterhood explores this universe or the
eyes of the mysterious order of women
the been a Jesuit whose extraordinary
mysterious mastery of body and mind
allows them to expertly weave through
the feudal politics and intrigue of the
Imperium so it is confirmed here that
this new show is actually based on Brian
Urban and Kevin J Anderson book The
Sisterhood of June and not necessarily
based on the lore bits found in Frank
Herbert's original 16 books and as you
all are probably aware of
there are some differences now I know
that a lot of people are immediately
turned off by this and they've expressed
as much on Reddit and on various dune
groups on the Internet
all I can say is I won't judge anything
until I see it but I wish them the best
of luck although I will say that it is
kind of weird that they took the page
down it's almost like they're trying to
hide the fact that it's based off of
Brian Herbers books and if they're doing
that and that's super weird
ok next there was also a cool image of
Paul that came out a couple of weeks ago
and I think it looks awesome the
carvings on the wall the decor in the
room is really appealing to me this
doesn't look at all like generic science
fiction so that is awesome and also
there's the technological looking thing
on Paul's left hand I'm almost certain
that this is a shield generator
now shields in the Dune universe play a
pretty significant role shield tech
makes conventional weapons pretty much
useless and the effect of laser guns on
shields is nuclear so that is avoided at
all cost so instead of guns the people
of the Dune universe often fight with
blades Paul is actually seen holding a
dagger here as you can see and when a
dagger is used with proper technique it
can actually penetrate the Holtzman
shield so this particular image if I had
to guess it's probably from the scene in
which Paul Atreides is training with
gurney Halleck in the beginning of doing
all right so that's all I have for you
guys right now if you want to support
this channel make sure you like and
subscribe you can also support this
channel by donating to my paypal link in
the description or pledging on patreon
and also clicking the join button right
below this video and on a side note
where is the Dune trailer we need it
right now hashtag released a dune
trailer I am so excited for this trailer
and I do not get excited for trailers in
general but I'm excited for this one I
don't even watch trailers typically for
something that I'm super interested in
but I really really want to see this one
because I know there's gonna be so much
in it that just gives us a peek into Dan
evil nose vision for the world and of
course I want to see the sand worm Who
am I kidding I want to see this
and that's the reason that I'm excited I
cannot wait to see what the beast looks
like I cannot wait to see the scale of
the desert there's so many reasons to be
excited for this I've got three
hardcover copies of the same book all
right release the goddamn trailer this
is not a joke to me release the trailer
we need it now I need it now
do it come on legendary get with it get
with can I be real with you guys for one
second in all seriousness I am worried
about the movie still being postponed it
doesn't look like this whole pandemic
mess isn't gonna be resolved by then so
weep the movie might not come out until
2021 it really might not and I a god I
really hope that's not the case but it
might be what they have to do because
people still might not be ready to go
into a crowded theater by the time
December hits it's still not certain so
there's there's a lot of reasons while
the trailer could be being held back so
I guess we'll see